they'll probably hang you buddy
in the late 1800s America was evolving
on its way to becoming the most powerful
country in the world new immigrants
arrived thriving outposts became towns
and civilization was spreading rapidly
to the huge wild and lawless frontier
with Red Dead Redemption too Rockstar
Games aims to create a living world
that's not simply open but deeper more
interactive and detailed than ever
combining action storytelling and
gameplay in new ways as you live ride
and fight to survive as an outlaw in a
notorious gang as long as we get paid
you get shot I'm happy
the game is an attempt to capture this
pivotal moment when the age of outlaws
was ending and the modern world was born
there is a huge world to explore sight
across a range of America's heartland
and frontier from harsh mountain trails
and dense forests to untamed swamp lands
and sweeping deserts rugged livestock
towns - modernizing cities and much more
all populated with a diverse cast of
characters from turn-of-the-century life
mouse shoe please
I'm waiting for someone interesting to
turn
you play as Arthur Morgan a trusted
senior gun in the vanderlin gang a band
of outlaws and outcasts on the run from
the pressures of civilized life once and
for all
[Music]
each time they're forced to flee an area
the gang sets up a camp as a base this
is where gang members eat sleep perform
chores play games and share stories
country sheriff these are the people
Arthur calls family and you will get to
know each gang member over the course of
the game so you save the silly bastards
laughs and you and him go Robyn she
helping the camp with food and supplies
will keep morale high while spending
time with other gang members can reveal
new secrets fun things to do and
opportunities for mischief go
redistribute some property in and out of
camp the world is alive and responds to
the player and your guns aren't the only
way to interact with the environment
call out to a passing rider talk
yourself into trouble with a local tough
guy or out of trouble with a town
sheriff or intimidate a witness into
silence and more
you don't want to involve yourself with
this confrontations can be escalated or
diffuse take it easy
do what you want home you can form
friendships or make enemies as you
choose your actions have consequences
and it's up to you to decide just how
honorable Arthur is should I have killed
you Jimmy Brooks shooting and fighting
have both been radically improved to
make combat deep and engaging at all
times each weapon has unique
characteristics with realistic reload
and recoil that always keeps the player
grounded and connected to the action in
a gunfight in a similar way the bond
with your horse is crucial and changes
based on your treatment of the animal
some breeds are better suited for
certain tasks like this for a while your
saddle and saddlebags can store extra
weapons along with supplies and animal
carcasses that you pick up while out
roaming or hunting over time the bond
between you and your horse will grow
making them easier to control in tense
situations yeah he's a great horse the
devil's got him a rich and varied
ecosystem thrives in the world full of
predators prey and scavengers all smart
and sometimes deadly you wanna come with
me I'll show you
hunting helps the camp or earns you
money wound an animal and you'll have to
track them down animal pelts and other
items you find can be traded for cash to
use at general stores gunsmiths saloons
and elsewhere this is God's own country
and I feel I'm in purgatory this is a
world that is rich in depth and detail
all designed to be explored on horseback
or on foot as you live the fateful
journey of a gang of Outlaws on the run
across America
in the next gameplay video we'll look at
missions activities enemy gangs
robberies other things to do and much
more
including the evolution of sharpshooting
using the Dead Eye system
[Music]
you